welcome back to the show they nap john
you have a very thriving comedy career
but you started out as a math teacher
yes
how did that matriculated
[Applause]
but yeah how did like a get to b
yeah and equals c right yeah
um
it was the only thing oh not the only
thing but it was the thing that i was
good at and you know it was like solid
like they say that if you have a degree
in like stem like the math science then
you'll always be good so i was studying
math because i didn't know anything else
and i got a degree and then my my father
passed away
um and i felt like in that moment
time was like of the essence you know
like i felt like when he passed away it
was so sudden
i just i don't know i had the thought
like well if tomorrow's my last day
i don't want to have any regrets
and when i thought that i packed up my
car
drove 3000 miles from new york to l.a
and
became a comedian
that's
so amazing you learn something right
yeah you go through that you learn just
how short life is so if there's
something you want you better start now
trying to get it yeah and also
and i didn't know this this this is
something that happened later um my
mother told me when i when i started
like getting good at comedy she was like
you know your father would be really
proud of you and i was like you think so
you think so and she was like yeah you
you know your father always wanted to be
a comedian
oh wow and i had no idea i'm like she
was like yeah you didn't know
and i'm like no i didn't know
you know wow and she was like yeah and
so when i first started comedy at first
because zainab is such a
you know unique name and johnson is just
like everybody right yeah i was gonna
drop johnson and then once my mom was
like well you know your father always
wanted to be a stand-up comedian i was
like i'm gonna keep johnson you know as
i perform
and and now i feel like this is gonna
sound so cheesy but now i feel like when
people announce me it's like my father
is doing what he wanted to do come on
that is so
meaningful
seriously that is so meaningful
really and truly and thank you for that
wisdom
life lesson
[Music]